le viaduc de millau un ouvrage
remarquable le plus grand pont du monde
avec un pilote à 343 mètres plus haut
que la tour eiffel le viaduc
impressionne ses visiteurs mais dans la
ville de millau il a dû se faire
accepter qu'un intérêt ça remplacera pas
le paysage dans les années 90 le projet
était de désenclaver la vallée du tarn
très embouteillé surtout lors des
vacances d'été
en 1994 des perspectives du pont sont
présentés aux millavois
outre le paysage dénaturer les
interrogations des locaux sont multiples
partout les ou les autoroutes pour les
revoir appris des existe on voit les
villages qui meurt le pont survolera le
tarn entre le causse rouge et celui du
larzac
mais entre les deux il y à des
exploitations agricoles bientôt jalonnée
de pylônes ça va diviser les
exportations ça va diviser même un état
d'esprit mais sinon ma une fois qui sera
réalisé la bande dans l'habitude et ça
sera joli joli pas joli pourront juger
il faut attendre 2004 le viaduc de
millau n'est pas encore mise en service
que déjà les curieux de toute la france
se précipitent des visites en car sont
organisés et déjà vu contre normandie
tancarville celui sur la loire et je
viens voir celui là que je juge que le
must par rapport à tout ce que j'ai vu
et les millavois alors avant l'ouverture
à la circulation
ils ont été invités à traverser le pont
et disons qu'ils ne se sont pas fait
prier je base de camp ne pas rouler à
130 euros
c'est trop bon de regarder
ok pour l'intégration de l' ouvrage dont
le paysage mais qu'en est il des
craintes exprimées dix ans auparavant
y en a qui croient que bob calvaire va
être ouvert mio ça va être une ville
déserte
moi je pense que non le contraire ça va
amener du monde d'ailleurs là on est au
milieu du mois de décembre et dans les
commerces et dans les restaurants il ya
de la clientèle étrangère rassurer à
millau le jour de l'ouverture le 16
décembre 2004 le pont connaît sa
première manifestation opération péage
gratuit mais les militants ne sont pas
là pour s'opposer au viaduc non ils se
l'approprient pour donner de la
visibilité à leur combat du jour la
sauvegarde des services publics
le viaduc s'est fait une place dans le
paysage dans le coeur des millavois et
dans l'économie locale
encore dix ans après la mise en service
des centaines de milliers de touristes
du monde entier venez le visiter
faisant souvent étape à millions
[Musique]